welcome everyone to this simultaneous
meeting of weber district council
cabinet and mid Suffolk District Council
cabinet mayor first will remind you of
some domestic arrangements please ensure
that microphones are turned off when not
in use please do not interrupt other
speakers if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave welcome everyone these are
obtained use the chat function only to
indicate that you wish to speak and not
to post comments or questions please
note that messages in the chat panel can
be viewed by people watching the live
broadcast I'd like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the Internet and will
be capable a repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council until the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded and I hand over to
Claire for the introductions of non
cabinet members thank you so in addition
to cabinet members we have with us today
councillor Alastair McCraw councillor
Andrew Mellon councillor andrew stringer
councillor daniel Pratt Lavinia heading
in councillor penny Otten councillor
Richard mayor Council of Robert Lindsay
and councillor Sarah Mansell or so sorry
Chancellor James Caston
and we in addition to that we also have
our chief executive officer Bonilla and
I monitoring officer Emily yield along
with officers who will be presenting
thank you
it's me out I think sorry counselor John
feels as well and I think you missed me
as Keith Wellum apologies
Thank You Claire right okay moving on to
item 1 apologies for absence believe we
have council a halt has his apologies I
will do a roll call Thanks thank you
thank you thank you baby councillors
councillor Clive Alfie present
councillor Dave Busby yeah
councillor Derrick Davis yeah councillor
Michael Holt sorry apologies from
councillor hope
councillor Elizabeth now VC calcium LBC
or immutably present counselor John
Osborne present else Linda Parker
present counselor John Ward present
councillors counselor
Jared Brewster present that's the David
Byrne present how's the Judi Flatman
present absolute Jessica Fleming present
councillor Peter gold present council
Suzie Morley present mm-hmm that's
Lahari Richardson present counselor John
Whitehead present Thank You chair Thank
You Pat item 2 to receive declarations
of pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest
by members are there any to declare nope
item three questions by councillors no
received yeah okay thank you I guess all
the questions we do have will be related
to the main item on on the agenda which
now leads me to move to that item which
is item four on the agenda that's paper
BCA 1957 and MCA 1966 the Environment
and climate change task force proposals
to cabinet first of all I'd like to
invite the paper cabinet member for
Environment to introduce the report
customer vici thank you chant as
councillors we joined politics for many
different reasons
ultimately it is to improve life for our
communities and neighbourhoods climate
change has been an our agenda for some
time now but it's this last year where
it has become a real priority for
everyone not just in our district or
County but in our country as well as the
world but this is not the only
international emergency in which we
found ourselves playing a key part the
corona virus pandemic has impacted on us
all and it's expected that as a result
the global emissions will fall between
five and ten percent with the UK having
a potential to be greater than that
granted for the most part we had a
period of excellent dry weather climate
change per chance the skies were clearer
the rivers cleaner there were more birds
and our grass verges tried hard to
emulate a meadow the council's response
to the pandemic has been incredible as
has the change in our behavior
demonstrating that if there is the will
there is also the way but it's due to
the overall kovat 19 response that our
plans for climate change have not been
presented sooner luckily we were able to
meet four times to gather the
information needed on which to base our
final proposals however I'm sure you
will join me and the task force team in
thanking the officers for their hard
work and commitment during a period of
unprecedented pressure
I personally am very grateful all their
effort
singly and jointly as with any emergency
you must act without delay yet remain
level-headed this is why we have
continued to keep a range of initiatives
as part of our business as usual
operations while basing our next steps
on considered expert analysis and advice
to ensure we have maximum effect for our
communities our proposals build on work
that's already taken place or is
currently taking place we already play a
key role in several environmental
partnerships and initiatives including
tree for life suffer climate change and
the Suffolk wastes partnerships and we
also offer paperless billing to all our
residents I was very keen that as soon
as the opportunity arose we were able to
get this important work back on track
our councillors are united in our desire
to tackle the issue of climate change
now following a lot of hard work
cross-party collaboration and with the
benefit of expert advice we're ready to
put forward our proposals about how we
can deliver real change to achieve our
aspiration of becoming carbon neutral by
2030 but before I move on I'd like to
say another thank you thank you to all
of the task force for embracing digital
processes in the latter part of our work
work which has enabled this paper to be
presented to you today
working in partnership will be will be
the key to our success there are many
elements to the plan before you today
which is imperative we want to work with
our leisure providers to move to green
energy tariffs because at the moment
they generate one third of our emissions
also we need to work with circle to
ensure our waste fleet significantly
reduces its emissions both now and in
the future since they generate in the
region of 25% of our emissions even in
just these two examples we have the
opportunity to work with the other local
authorities and Suffolk to see how we
can tackle this together because at the
end of the day
a change affects us all the first carbon
reduction management plan is the first
of many that will help us to reduce both
councils current emissions of
approximately five thousand four hundred
and fifty two tonnes of carbon dioxide
equivalent which is co2e per year to Net
Zero while also ensuring we invest in
the right solutions remember Net Zero
came into law twelve months ago and as a
nation we are committed to net zero
emissions by 2050 we'll continue to work
with partners across the county the
region including our town and parish
council towards the suffolk wide
ambition to be carbon neutral by 2020
however we know we can't do this alone
our residents and businesses all need to
be taking small tips steps to becoming
more environmentally conscious such as
only buying what you need wasting less
and cycling and walking more over coming
months we'll be exploring even more
possibilities with a taskforce subgroup
looking at how we can strengthen our
biodiversity I said at the start of my
introduction that I became a counselor
to make a positive change I truly
believe that by working together the way
we have so far we can ensure beba and
mid Suffolk continue to be plated places
we're proud to call home for generations
to come and that we continue to make our
positive contribution to making Suffolk
a greener County it therefore gives me
pleasure to propose to the Baber cabinet
that you adopt the plan before you at
three point one and three point three
thank you Thank You councillor Murphy
see may I have a seconder from the day
the cabinet please if I'm happy to
second that myself if there's no others
I will second that myself Thank You
councillor Molly and I will now invite
the mid Suffolk cabinet member for
Environment to introduce the report
councillor Fleming
yes Thank You counselor Molly and thank
you everyone who this is some in the
room today it is my pleasure to bring
these proposals to the mid Suffolk
cabinet for consideration and approval
they are the result of a lot of hard
work by the task force group members and
the officers who have supported us I
would like to mention a special thank
you to our officer Cass Clements who has
been through this journey with us all
the way and has managed the numerous and
sometimes conflicting comments and
suggestions from our meetings
she has introduced helpful guest
speakers to us and after several
iterations has produced a set of
proposals which capture the best ideas
that came from the group we are now
ready to accept these ideas and take
them forward into meaningful actions I
will not repeat the messages from our
paper about the two commitments by both
districts to respond to the climate
emergency because they're in in our
papers except to say that every member
of the task force has contributed
constructively to the proposals in front
of us we don't all necessarily agree on
everything but I think we all do agree
that the health of the natural
environment which includes climate
change in biodiversity is one of the
most important probably the most
important concern of our time
recognizing this there is the widely
felt sense that priorities of all areas
of decision-making at all levels of
government need to change substantially
the work that this group has started is
the beginning here in Suffolk as we
consider the various proposals for our
first carbon reduction management plan
ie appendix a I would like to emphasize
that the proposals reflect five meetings
actually four and a half as one was
focused on biodiversity so customer base
is correct there as well as comments
from
members and senior officers and a
technical report from groundworks
which we commissioned they are in effect
a set of actions that we believe are
ready to set in motion now pending
additional investigation and costing
several of the proposals will require
cooperation with our county and district
colleagues which are all following
similar paths and our joint working with
them will add value and purchase what we
wish to receive both councillor mal vici
and I sit on the countywide
climate change committee and unaware
that her relevant offices also liaised
regularly with each other across the
county and districts and with other
local authorities in England the County
Council policy development panel is
bringing its recommendations to the
county cabinet later in this month and
this is remarkable but reassuring to
learn that their proposals are very
similar and complementary to ours for
example in areas such as low carbon
energy purchasing building construction
transport waste and procurement we are
all taking talking from the same hymn
sheet and we will benefit from working
together to achieve as much benefit as
possible there are also areas where we
can work constructively when it comes to
biodiversity and land management getting
the balance right for things like
roadside verges and working with
community organisations in parish
councils and I'm excited at the prospect
of what we can all to achieve addressing
the enormous scale of climate and
environmental problems this daunting
visit as with most things that matter
each small step in the right direction
is important and collectively they
matter a lot we've heard a glimpse
during the pidemo
of how rapidly nature can respond when
given space it should not take that to
show us what the potential is when we
change the way we do things
I do hope that these proposals are
acceptable to you bloom on the
respective cabinets and that we can now
move on to the next stage thank you
Thank You councillor Fleming can I have
a seconder from mid Suffolk thank you
Thank You councillor whitehead chairman
yes I'm pleased to second the
recommendation set out in the report in
section of three I suspect some mid
Suffolk opposition members may have
concerns when they see me as part of the
sign-off process on proposals but let me
reassure them that I do care for our
planet and its environment and I do
understand that we all have serious
responsibilities and obligations when it
comes to the human activities driving
global warming it's clear to me that the
carbon sorry the cabinet carbon
reduction plan will not come cheap
in my introductory speech to the 1920
budget at mr. but full council back in
February I said it is crystal clear to
me if we have to take real action on
climate change then real money will need
to be set aside this half million pounds
is just a start of a 2021 now I did say
those words precoded but I still believe
them to be valid I see it as being both
a privilege and responsibility to be one
of the two legged individual cabinet
members given this delegated authority
by cabinet I very much look forward to
working with a cabinet member for the
environment and the section 1 5 1
officer as each proposal comes forward
for funding I suspect several proposals
will affect both districts and therefore
I will look forward to also hearing
those debated by Babers cabinet or
Council as part of the overall process
so to reiterate madam chairman I'm happy
to second this report and its
recommendations thank you Thank You
councillor why did councillor Ward Thank
You Carson Wally and before we move on
to questions
Cassandra Clements is going to be giving
a short presentation to members so if I
can hand over to to you Cass please
Thank You chairman and thank you
everybody for coming to this
simultaneous cabinet this afternoon on
this clearly very important topic
and as my portfolio holders have already
said there has been a lot of work go on
from the task force and from my team who
if I could indulge slightly and thank
them as well here on the call with us
today so I am going to attempt to share
my screen with you and just go through a
few slides that talks us through how we
got to this report today okay can
everybody see that
hopefully that's showing lovely thank
you okay so as Jessica and Elizabeth of
Oh Eddie
said the climate change task force was
convened in response to the climate
change motions that the council's passed
in July 2019 and the role of the task
force there was to make recommendations
on how the two councils can protect and
improve the environment looking at what
opportunities are available and
technology that is becoming through and
opportunities to work with partners it
was also to consider how best to embed
those considerations for both climate
change and biodiversity ambitions in all
decision making going forward alongside
the wider social and economic factors
and finally to recommend an approach to
how we look at delivering net zero
carbon emissions for both councils by
2030 the task force looked at a number
of topics including low carbon energy
biodiversity planning housing waste and
transport and travel and a final meeting
culminated in a discussion across all of
those topics on all of the possible
opportunities that vapour amid suffer
councils how to take forward a number of
experts were called in to talk to us and
the task force had the opportunity to
not only listen but to question those
experts to be able to bring
proposals forward today they included
greater southeast energy hub Suffolk
Wildlife Trusts
Dennis Eagle groundwork suffix and the
number of my assistant director
colleagues and corporate managers so the
report talks about the data however I
just wanted to touch on this briefly in
my slides in that our baseline data came
from 2018-19 and here's 5452
you will see a breakdown of the two
highest impact as being leisure centers
and waste collection and I'll talk to
Lee in a second about what we can do
about those and the small table on the
right there just shows you the split
between the three different scopes that
we've considered a number of councils
haven't considered scope three in their
presentations but this was a key factor
that the task force were keen that both
councils ensured all three scopes were
included in our proposals
so the two main areas have been impacted
you've just seen or the leisure centers
and also the waste fleet what you'll see
from the proposal before you today is
there are a number of interim solutions
as well as some longer term aspirations
the two interim solutions here
particularly for leisure centers is
around moving to green energy tariffs
we're currently on blue energy tariffs
there's a lot of work that needs to go
on around that and the task force
members will be very clear that there
this is still a tricky area you have to
make sure that the source of that energy
is correct and that how that energy is
procured is correct however that would
decrease our emissions fairly
significantly almost immediately by
changing those tariffs the long term
opportunity around that is around our
own energy generation the second there
is around our waist fleet and the
interim measure here is suggested to
move to a biofuel hvo and that will work
on all of our current euro-6 engine
vehicles so you can move straight from
diesel to biofuel without any changes to
the vehicles the long term solution of
course is going to be a different
solution potentially electric
potentially hydro however that is a
technology that is is still emerging at
the moment and that's why you'll see
that there isn't a definitive
proposal around exactly what we will do
going forward
however absolutely our aspiration is to
move away from diesel vehicles
completely so you'll see the report
proposals follow a similar pattern to
the topics that the task force looked at
however they were clearly many more
opportunities available to us and so the
list in front of you you'll see some
additional categories around our council
and commercial estate customer
transformation business communities
culture change and governance and so the
faizal's before you today cover all of
those themes the report talks about next
steps and that will include going
through our program boards to ensure
that we have business cases for each
individual project that comes forward
that we thoroughly understand the
viability of the projects the costs and
the impacts and they in turn will form
out part of our formal performance
process at that point I'll hand back
over to you two for questions thank
thank you gasps right we'll now move on
to the the question stage firstly
questions from paper members I do want
to keep the focus on questions early on
and items of clarification on the report
in front of us and that any other
discussions we will hold over for the
debate later on so Baber members do you
have any questions firstly counselor our
fee sorry chairman I didn't know you
were on a roll one at a time just just
to make sure we've got everyone covered
so now I don't have any questions I was
a member of the task force as you know
and I think we've done quite well to
pull everything together as the two
portfolio holders have said so no I
don't have any question thank you
Thank You councillor Busby do you have
any questions at this stage it's just a
small one D the used vegetable vegetable
oil that we're proposing to use in the
waste fleet where are we voting to get
this oil from would you like me to take
that yeah Cass yes could you answer that
please sure and so we're currently
developing a business case on where the
oil will come from there are a number of
different options for this and however
we have to be very careful about the
actual origin the best-case scenario is
being able to you - as you mentioned use
used vegetable oil there are some local
companies actually that do that and so
three of the business case will be
developing exactly who the originator of
that oil will be and but at the moment
that's not yet decided and that will be
something that comes back to cabinet for
decision thank you thanks Council of
Davis no I'm all good thank you very
much
capsule ml VC no I'm okay thank you
Catherine yeah Thank You mr. chairman
I would like some clarification first of
all if I can just say I think this is a
really really big step forward and well
done to all those that have been
involved in getting to the stage that
we've got to
clarification on page 15 nine point
three and nine point four nine point
three says that approval for any funding
will come from the transformation fund
and the general fund and the
recommendation makes this clear as well
that the cabinet member for the
environment will have delegated powers
to make that decision I'm a little bit
concerned because there will be some
hard to say is really know if I can if I
could just finish Liz and then it might
become clearer and can I can I just
confirm because there may be some hard
decisions to make when it comes to
expenditure in the HRA with with us you
know delicate balancing act between
delivering homes and spending on the
environment I would like to see in that
recommendation or made clearer that the
cabinet member for Finance at Weber and
the cabinet member for housing will be
involved in that delegated decision when
it comes to given permission to spend
that finance on any actions that come
forward
okay can I answer this counselor VZ yes
if you read on the recommendations three
point three and it only applies to us in
Baber that the cabinet member for
environment be given delegated authority
to consider the business case for each
proposal and to present options to
either the cabinet to agree funding from
the transformation Innovation Fund or to
the Council
to agree funding from the general fund
so that there is no delegated
decision-making other than establishing
the business case and presenting so the
decision is made by cabinet and full
counsel I'm just reading the I'm just
reading the recommendation now if I may
and it's three point three of the
recommendations that the cabinet member
for the environment be given delegated
authority to consider the business case
for each proposal and to present options
to either the cabinet to agree funding
from the transformation fund an
Innovation Fund or the general fund it
doesn't make any mention to who's going
to be given delegated power on the
expenditure of the business case for the
HRA and the cabinet member for housing
at paper needs to be involved in that
decision-making on the business case
proposals right we would need we'll come
back to that later
councillor Osborn you're quite right it
does need to reference the HRA we'll
come back to that in a minute thank you
thank you thanks okay
councillor Parker no questions Jen at
the moment right and and I don't either
so are now asked for questions from any
other members of that the bebo counsel
present at this meeting
note that for other members non cabinet
members in terms of the questions a
number of the questions I'm sure will be
focused on the contents of the report
and for clarification and and for those
we will provide answers immediately but
I would like to be able to park any more
detail questions on on other issues for
the cabinet debate that depending on the
nature of the question because it's is
clear I think that some questions that
non cabinet members may wish to ask
would benefit from a wider debate
a quick answer at this stage so are
there any members of the labor council I
have counselor McCraw has indicated he
wishes to ask a question and then I've
got councillor Lindsay
so council McCraw first of all apologize
chair for that delay there it's a point
of clarification on the recommendation
as referred to by councillor Osborn I
think it's important just to stress this
point rather than delegated decisions
being made my understanding of this
paper and the general thrust of it is
that the final decisions under three
point three and I may have stressed the
final decisions will either be made by
cabinet or by council whether they are
general fund or HRA and I think it's
good and important to clarify that that
this is not going to be a delegated
decision the fundamental final authority
comes down to one of two cabinet or
council thank you verified and perhaps
we can maybe get that clarify the little
by adjusting the amendment to reflect
that well that they could own the HRA
yeah I was going to come on to that when
we get to the the actual cabinet debate
itself but but clearly we need to do
that and then yes it will very much be
our the cabinet or Council to make that
final decision on the financing Castle
and Lindsay Thank You chair a big part
of our carbon emissions will be indirect
through for example through investments
that we're making through the pension
through the pension fund and in our
Treasury function through shows
Schroeder's which is invested in in the
stock market I did suggest as one of my
proposals during the process was that we
write to Suffolk pension fund committee
and asked them to cut their exposure to
fossil fuel companies and that wasn't
accepted
even though actually I mean I sit on the
Suffolk pension committee and they have
actually already moved some funds into
low-carbon funds so I'm just wondering
Roeder's I understand we have nine
percent of the assets and Schroeder's
are in fossil fuel companies and so I'm
just wondering why that was ruled out
thank you okay Thank You Carol Lindsey
obviously you'll know from our treasury
management strategy that sip fir does
require councils to invest prudently and
with a high regard for security and
liquidity and as we ourselves in that
treasure management strategy have said
that we will invest for security
followed by liquidity and followed by
yield in those orders and then those
that that defines our investment
strategy and we will continue to follow
that but and so that will determine
exactly where we invest our funds and
the types of organisations we invest in
but in terms of fossil fuel and I know
you and I have probably had well you
probably know my views on this because I
think we have discussed it and many
times in the past the fossil fuel
companies are so-called fossil fuel
companies are rapidly becoming energy
companies that they alone have the
resources to financial and other
resources to move to a zero carbon
future I don't think it makes any sense
at all to try to penalize them when we
should be encouraging them to be part of
that process so just having an
ideological dislike us company because
it's a fossil fuel company I don't think
we'll have a beneficial effect in the
long term in terms of the pension fund
councillor Whitehead you you're also a
member of that aren't you I believe you
have some some views on on that would
you like to comment at this stage
um yes can you hear me yep yeah the
reality is that the Suffolk pension fund
which is a defined benefit fund there is
a responsibility fiscal responsibility
on the investment of over 3 billion
pounds of pension fund money to protect
and target approximate risk adjusted
investment returns and of course any
shortfall would fall back on the
employers and ultimately then on our
council taxpayers so it's it's important
and produced reduce it due to we have
there but the committee are actively
discussing this as casually as it will
know and that some of the passive
previous passive investments have been
switched to climate aware climate where
fund and we're looking very closely at
all the environmental social and
governance practices of all the
companies that we invest in Thank You
counsel Whitehead I know that Castle
rotten has their hand up and if I can
hold off until we get to the mid Suffolk
section please counselor awesome but in
the meantime are there any other
questions from other members of Labor
Council I don't see any other hands up
at this stage
okay um Harvey see it's just to point
out that the the so called fossil fuel
companies are the very companies that
are doing the major research in
alternative energy streams so it's it's
a dichotomy I bill I agree but I I think
that we need to steer a middle road and
a straight road because these guys are
investing a lot of money
and it needs that investment to be able
to drive the replacement and alternative
fuels and and she'll have recently
signed an agreement with a start-up
that's got two hydrogen distribution
facilities and are working closely with
them to provide a distribution network
for um hydrogen for all road vehicles
you've got to bear in mind that you need
gas to make hydrogen yeah at the moment
yeah yeah well okay moving on then to
questions from the mid suffer cabinet
members firstly councillor Brewster do
you have any questions Thank You
chairman um yeah first of all I would
like to applaud the the the task force
who have done obviously a really hard
work at getting these put forward I do
have a question which which I have very
good reason to ask and car-parking
review can I ask just how that will be
carried out what its likely to bring
forward not one fear is that if we have
ten centers which don't have car parking
which is attractive to those who want to
go on them that they will just shoot out
of towns on to the out of town stores to
do their shopping and hence the town
centers will miss out okay Thank You
councillor Brewster um would anyone Cass
would you be able to provide a response
on that regarding car parking hello yes
of course and so the the car parking
with you and I think has to go
hand-in-hand with some of the visioning
work that my colleague Fiona Duomo is
doing as well because you're absolutely
right car parking affects everybody it's
about business it's about users what we
need to do is ensure that we have
alternate options for people to access
town centers so walking cycling
absolutely and a good public transport
network then with the car parks that
remain what we need to make sure is that
we have opportunity for turnover so
where people need to access for a short
amount of time they can do that and that
the car parks aren't all full and with
you know people staying all day so it's
a combination of making sure that the
spaces are available for the right
people in the right places but also
importantly that those other options are
developed to try and get and the
emissions down and the air quality up
within our urban areas thank you gasps
okay
councillor bird Thank You chairman
no points of clarification at this time
thank you thank you
councillor Flatman no not at this time
chair Thank You councillor Fleming do
you have anything you want to say at
this stage um no I would just say that I
was going to add in response to
councillor Brewster's question that but
Cass has said it very well better than I
could thank you thank you castle of gold
no questions at this point
thank you very much chair Gosselaar
Morni no questions chair Thank You
councillor Richardson I had no questions
for me Thank You chair and councillor
whitehead no questions yeah okay thank
you before I invite questions from other
bid Suffolk castle members understand
that castle Lindsay has has another
question from from Weber so castle
Lindsay would you like to ask that now
thanks very much for letting me ask
another question
sure yeah it was in similar vein no
tsypko the new business strategy is to
increase investment in drive-through
restaurants how is that compatible with
cutting carbon to zero by 2030 thank you
my colleague and Emily ATAC to provide
two response yeah okay thanks Emily
would you like to yes that's fine and so
the business planning to do for
discussion at full council in July and
the draft version was discussed at
overview and scrutiny in in June so the
papers will soon be submitted with the
revised proposals and
in the next 10 days or so and the
category that you're referring to was
approximately eight to ten percent of
the portfolio as a whole and referred to
food and breath food and beverage so
that includes restaurants cafes etc of
which a small proportion of that could
have been drive-through operations and
the board have Cisco have reviewed their
policy in this regard
since overview and scrutiny and are
willing to remove the reference to
drive-through and properties in the
forthcoming investment strategy it was
very minor part of the strategy in any
event with the majority of investment
focused on industrial and other assets
rather than drive-through properties so
I hope that helps to answer that
question Thank You Emily but also
drive-throughs are a perfectly
legitimate part of the market they are
in demand and people do like them
they're convenient and at some point in
the future they'll be driving to them in
electric or other vehicles anyway so
again it concerns me that we that their
suggestions that we make these these
gestures without realizing that the full
impact turned and the benefit that some
of these businesses provide for our
communities anyway moving on to the mid
Suffolk members I've got councillors I
take it in in the order I've got in the
list here in front of me so castle
stringer first of all thank you chair to
speak I take it you can hear me okay yes
you have a question I began the meeting
I have to say quite optimistic and and
I've now become quite depressed at what
I've heard do you have a question
counselor yes I have yes okay if you
want I'll just mute now go away yes not
going to be choked off like that this is
too important
and not political I've said I would I
would ask the officers who signed off on
paragraph 12.4 it is very very anti
change and very anti science it seems to
be worrying about disruption if it
wasn't for disruption we wouldn't be
using ballpoint pens we will still be
using ink wells and quills you know we
really and to suggest that a technology
is emerging is is renewable energy been
using renewable energy for well over a
thousand years battery storage over a
century and energy efficiency since we
first crawled into caves so actually
that use and saying it's an emerging
technology means that we are suspicious
of it and we somehow don't trust it
like the we've I've heard the term
alternative energy no such thing in
science there is either energy where
there isn't it's quite simple you know
there's no such thing as alternative it
is it either is in being or it isn't so
to use those kind of that kind of
language is actually anti science and it
is anti
moving on to where we have agreed we
need to be what was the question the
council a stringer can we amend 12.4
please no I think that your
interpretation of it was is a bit unfair
and it's not how I read that paragraph
right good moving on Casper field
John so I was just having microphone
switching on problems again yes
couple of points really obviously having
been on the working party pretty
familiar with the document so no
detailed questions there they did seem
to be to me seeking some assurance that
we do intend to crack on with things
that are good pace I mean taking counsel
so whiteheads point that that is not
going to be achieved without money and
you know we might be somewhat short of
that in the future but we this is
desperately important I so are we going
to get on with it good right the other
sort of issue was really the decision
process in Biber that you discussed at
some length
lots of assurance oh that's really true
for mid Suffolk as well and the final
point isn't a question I guess but just
the issue that on fossil fuel companies
we didn't use coal companies to develop
oil and there's no specific reason why
we should use oil companies to develop
hydrogen or wind power or whatever no
reason why we shouldn't if they're going
in the right direction but we don't have
to link the two together quite that
firmly
Thank You Katherine Fleming do you wish
to pick up on the questions that
Castlefield has raised well I think the
thank you you know the comparison of
coal to oil versus the major oil
companies in the world to the
development of renewables on a global
scale I don't think def is really a
like-for-like comparison castle afield
I'm sorry I think I'm coal is a very
different thing and I'm also very aware
feeling having worked in the oil
industry and still knowing a lot of
people who work in it that companies
like she'll BP etc are absolutely
hell-bent on developing whatever energy
source they can sell and that is going
to be
low-carbon energy in the future so I
think calomel VC has an extremely good
point thank you great thanks castle
phone what about councillor feels
questions about the speed of
implementation and also the the actual
process at mid Suffolk for agreeing to
spend on any individual proposal well I
think um and I can assure you that mid
Suffolk we are going to take what I hope
are the approved proposals forward as
soon as we can I would add and this may
be more for debate but there are a
number of these proposals that will
benefit and need collaboration with our
colleagues at the other neighboring
authorities because we can all work much
better and more effectively together but
I know that all of us are you'll see
this is an extremely high priority and
even in these times when we're all short
of money I think this is this is the big
change that we're seeing happen our
priorities are changing and with it the
flow of our resources so I'm very
optimistic and as cabinet member I don't
intend to let this lag I don't know
whether tests you'd like to say anything
yes of course so in terms of times go I
think the two main areas have impact
being the leisure centre tariffs and the
biofuel option I would absolutely be
looking to come back to cabinet this
financial year with fully scoped
business cases on those and with an
implementation timeline of this
financial year obviously there are lots
of other areas that we start those
business cases off straight away and so
the team and I will be sitting down and
looking at and what resources we need to
make sure that those happened and of
course they'll go through the council's
program boards to help develop those and
so yes work will be happening on this
plan immediately and some has already
started pleased to hear that
what about the decision process will it
be delegated or of the saw
that was mentioned former Bateman so for
me to Suffolk and it has been delegated
for the cabinet member for environment
and the cabinet member for Finance in
consultation with a section one five one
officer to consider the beaches in this
cases but then that will they will look
to approve the funding for each case and
so the decision-making is with is
delegated to those and cabinet members
in consultation with the section one
five one officer Thank You counsel then
councillor Pratt chairman reading
through the document I'm interested in
on your paragraphs at three point three
particularly about planning and the
impact on the emerging local plan the
fact of the matter is that all of this
has got to be embedded in any new local
plan and therefore I am concerned with
the statement that says must not ensure
this action does not cause delay to the
current local plan timetable what we
don't want surely is for us to go
through the whole process have the local
plans signed off where we haven't
actually embedded our views on how
planning policy must be part of our
climate change actions and therefore I
really need to have it assured that
somewhere that will that action will
take place and we also have got to be
able by having that embedded and written
in a local plan therefore be able to
resist any there I say resistance by any
future developers I think we'll all
agree that the current developments
going across me
at the moment have had to fall by the
wayside where certain environmental
issues have not been able to be enforced
Thank You Cass Clawson oh yeah I don't
want this debate to move on to the the
joint local plan but would either Castle
it burn or Pat's councillor Aarthi be
able to provide some assurance to
councillor often over the question I'll
have a crack if you want I won't go into
great detail but I have spoken to Tom
Barker about this obviously we don't
want the emerging JLP to not be able to
accommodate what we're trying to do here
and I think the simple answer is none of
what we're seeking to approve today is
in conflict with the emerging JLP so in
other words there may be some small
policy tweaks that will help and some of
those have already been accommodated by
the working group and I don't believe
that there's anything in what we might
prove today that would be in conflict
with with the emerging plan so in other
words it will accommodate all of this I
don't know I mean I well I was just
about so I have spoken to Tom about this
and I think Tom's with us today is d so
he may want to chip in as well um I just
like to come back that cancer Aarthi I
don't think tweaks its appropriate
phrase if I may say so because I really
think it's got to be really highlighted
and underlined and emphasized we do not
as I say want to end up with a local
plan that we cannot therefore use as
evidence well can I come back on that as
well and I mean it as I say some of
these policies have been tweaked and I'm
not trying to say that you know that all
we're doing is a tweak to something that
was completely enough or likely to be
ineffective before if you have a look at
policy LP 20
three in the in the preferred options
document that was already picking up a
lot of the principles that are being
picked up in in this work so it's not as
if the local clan had nothing in it at
all
and we've tweaked it to put a little bit
in what I'm saying is that some of the
policies have been changed slightly by
the working group to strengthen them but
the the emerging JLP has already picked
up a lot of climate change initiatives
particularly with regard to low-carbon
sustainable construction all of that
sort of stuff
Thank You counsel the Bern do you have
anything that you wish to add to that
the council or something so I'm sorry
chair I was just looking something up to
to help with that answer and I think
running through the whole of the joint
local plan there there is a basic
premise that that has at its heart the
whole business of carbon reduction we
talk constantly of sustainability
measures etc etc the whole of the the
the development industry is expected to
contribute to that and we we do have a
number of policies that address the
issue directly it's it is not necessary
I don't think certainly not at this
stage to consider that only supplemented
planning documents or a complete raging
of the of the local plan is what's
required here so so for what reassurance
that is and I don't suppose it will be
too great you were reassuring to to my
colleagues on the other side of that out
of the chamber as it were
I'm I'm I'm a very ecologically minded
conservative if you like and I am I am
quite satisfied and that the local plan
does address these issues sufficiently
and satisfactorily at this stage and I
but and there's one thing I will say in
addition to that is that if it didn't we
would we would be in trouble
because I think we cannot afford any
further delays to to the to the
preparation of the plan we all know how
vital it is to the future of our
development in this in this district and
but I hope I can assure you that we we
have considered these points and that
they are well and truly embedded in it
Thank You Caliburn castle Mansell Thank
You chair I do have a question which
would like to ask and I may come back
with another question and some
supplementary if that's possible
my first question is about statement 3.2
in the decisions in the determination of
the business cases for each of the
climate change proposals how much weight
if any will be given to the social
dimension as opposed to a purely
financial or environmental dimension
Thanks Thank You councillor right who
does anyone want to capsule there
Fleming would you like to provide a
response to that well I'll do my best i
I think councillor Mansell you do make a
very good point we are as a local
authority bound by the is it the social
Environmental Quality Act correct me if
I'm wrong which requires councils to
consider their social and economical
effects of decision making and I think
we could probably as part of our
implementation of the
carbon reduction plan take a bit more
note of what we are supposed to be doing
here social environmental issues go
hand-in-hand
and I think that's I agree let's let's
make sure we include them in our just in
in how we carry this out going forward
thank you so I get them at bay birth at
the cafe that will take place when
deciding the financing will cover the
social dimensions as well yeah yeah but
but of course in mid Suffolk we've
allocated this five hundred thousand
pounds for this climate change proposals
and my another question is is if after
you've determined those business cases
and just need to quit interrupts castle
old war boys you're sharing your screen
can can you stop that so I didn't mean
to just I just stopped if once you've
determined those business cases it turns
out that the five hundred thousand is
insufficient and the proposals are still
deemed to be worthy because of their
environmental and social well-being
benefits have we got any option to go
back to full council to authorize
further funding either within this final
financial you know within this financial
year all beyond for any of the climate
change measures that are in your putting
the proposals would anyone from the mid
Suffolk cabinet like to pick up on that
castle Fleming Castle white-haired your
customer that's okay I mean as far as
I'm concerned if there is a strong
business case for further money then
we'd go back to full council for the
money I mean it's not a bottomless pit
but I always said half millions of
starter thank you for that reassurance
cancer Whitehead I mean I I person you
know I think that climate change is is
is important and maybe half a million
isn't enough
you know we've set ourselves a very high
target of going carbon neutral by 2030
although I think councilman VZ may have
actually misread and said 2020 which
might be a bit of a tall order but even
even if we do it by 2030 it's gonna call
it it's likely to cost us money and we
have to be prepared to spend that money
so thank you and and also thank you to
catch the Fleming for her reassurance
the social dimension will be taken into
consideration alongside the other issues
when you come to determine the business
case thank you very much can I just add
something um I just want to say that you
know our trajectory that we're starting
on isn't going to suddenly it's not a
one-time event this this is something
that's continuous for the future so I
would head actually be bold enough to
say that of course half a million pounds
isn't isn't the end of it this is
something that will be going on into the
future
you know after I'm retired and under the
sword I heard yeah it's it's certainly
it isn't it's endure thank you
Thank You councillor Fleming you really
are looking a long way into the future
then councillor Willem Thank You chair
um can I ask what's happened to counsel
Rachel he burns questions she submitted
a question to emily you'll and I was
anticipating that that would be asked is
somebody going to ask that question or
shall I
I think it was submitted after the the
the deadline and that we were probably
expecting calorie burn to ask it in
person but if you would like to ask it
on her behalf that's you know you're
quite welcome to do that
Thank You chair I've got her question
and I've got my own question I'm gonna
ask my own question first because it
does follow on to a degree from what
councillor Mansell was saying and
council Fleming rightly said that miss
effort will need to work with other
authorities mid stuff we have committed
half a million pounds to spend this year
so right
concern is and I wonder if you've
discussed this with Baber district
council whether or not they will be able
to commit the same sort of level of
funds for joint projects and and also
you know concerned that there appear to
be different arrangements in terms of
authorization to spend
I wonder if cancel them
Fleming could respond to that please I'm
not sure it's really for me to respond
to that we can't really speak on behalf
of Babel perhaps as the cabinet member
for Finance of Bayboro I can say that we
did not allocate the half a million and
longer lives that mid Suffolk did simply
because we did not have that money to
spare from our transformation fund but
we will be looking at each individual
project each individual initiative and
the cabinet will determine and debate
the funding for that or all the council
will I can't make any promises or
guarantees at this stage Council well I
mean it will very much depend on the
projects as they come forward the costs
and what money we have available at
paper at the time so we will obviously
do our best to to match and to work in
step with mid Suffolk obviously we're
working in partnership and this this is
very much a joint venture for both of us
and so we will do our best but I can't
make any particular promises at this
stage well I'm grateful for that but but
my concern is that we miss up that miter
identified projects which would be more
beneficial if they were joint projects
but would we still be prepared to go
ahead with projects even if Baber could
not match fund would anyone from itself
I respond yes any Castle flaming yeah I
I understand exactly what you're saying
councillor Willem and I think you know
what we're seeing here is the obviously
these sort of some of the fundamental
differences between the two Council
somehow they operate in funding fund
their their work but I see going forward
that these differences are going to
become less and I think if projects are
important I am confident that Babur
council will find the money to work with
us and that there won't be a disjoint if
there is then I think we'll address it
when it comes up but I think it's a
problem that hasn't happened yet
glad anything perhaps I can add
something as well
mid Suffolk we don't only work with
paper obviously we work most closely
with Baber but some of our initiatives
are across the whole of the county and
though our Baber colleagues may decide
that they don't want to follow an
initiative or in terms of timing follow
our timescales that does not preclude
it's not working with anybody else
East Suffolk West Suffolk hips which
county we will work with anyone that
will help us deliver to our targets yeah
yes thank you yeah I actually understood
that from councillor Fleming's
presentation and and an answer to a
previous question shall I go on -
Rachel's council racially Burns question
yes please which is why isn't the
cabinet sharing political leadership by
taking the opportunity to convene a
citizen's assembly or similar to address
climate change across the district
engaging all residents businesses and
organisations as many other councils of
all political persuasions across the
country have done I think no one jump
well to be honest um Ollie I would like
to save that for our debate later
because I think there's something that
the cabinet the two cabinet's together
probably need to need to discuss it is
more than just a quick answer to that to
that question I don't know how you feel
about that okay fair enough yeah yeah oh
yes I think that would be the best way
forward yes thank you okay castle wall
boys
Thank You counsel award yes I have got a
question but I don't really like being
pedantic there's a couple of points I
must sort of clarify first of all I did
enjoy councillor mal visas opening
comments and I felt the spirit of them
was really very well intended but I must
corrected that you don't need gas to
produce hydrogen hydrogen is also
produced by electrolysis and at the
moment there's more there's a crossover
point and now more gas is produced by
electrolysis than it is from methane or
other hydrocarbons in terms of emerging
technologies London Transport already
runs a fleet of double-decker buses
built in Belfast powered by hydrogen
produced by wind farms in the Thames
Estuary yes the technology is there
admittedly the network is limited but it
exists and looking at countries across
Europe it is a growing and incredibly
important part of the economy that my
main question was for you councillor
Ward it was about the treasury
management strategy from your remarks it
seemed to me clear that you were looking
for the best value for investments I had
taken sort of advice from a previous
briefing from our offices and it was
quite clear that - what - our investment
strategies there should be an ethical
and community dimension it's not just
getting the best value for money I think
my point being is that the best way to
get the oil industry to invest in non
oil energy sources is to take is to
divest investments from them so my
question is is he absolutely sure that
we really are taking a proper ethical
and community values into into account
with our treasury management strategy
Thank You capsule war boys I didn't say
to get the best value I was quite clear
that our strategy is security first
followed by liquidity followed by yield
so yield or value or income or whatever
is is the third of those criteria in
terms of that I think we will probably
agree to disagree on on the the fossil
fuel companies I don't think by dissing
by divesting our investments from them
is the way forward we should be
encouraging them to move in the
direction of being energy companies the
last thing that we need to do is is to
harm their their financial capability to
do that but I guess that's that's going
to be a philosophical or political
difference that we have your original
comment about I take your point about
hydrogen yes it is increasingly being
produced from electrolysis of seawater
using an electrical energy from wind
turbines and and that for me is is
excellent it's it's got to be the way
forward and I see increasingly that
hydrogen from that source will become
the primary fuel for vehicles I think it
has a more viable future than battery
technology quite honestly and it doesn't
have the drawbacks of battery technology
in terms of the resources that the
batteries require and the questionable
means by which those resources are
obtained from countries abroad so that's
one thing that I think we can all agree
on with regard to hydrogen so I've got
castleball why do you have anything else
you wanted to ask well yes I think that
to the the interim strategy of using
biofuels I think it will be
is it a limit on that for this sort of
lifetime of the existing diesel engines
and
when it comes to the point at which
those engines I replace would they be
replaced by something other than diesel
or biofuel based I don't
biofuel as a as a sustainable energy
source perhaps can people okay I mean on
that no we renew our feet every seven
years so the next renewal is about 2023
whether that's the feasible time for
moving off biofuels onto something else
I don't know castle Fleming can i yes I
am actually
counselor war boys even absolutely agree
with you on both the issue of batteries
and hydrogen and biofuels I think one of
the things that I I think we discussed
at the taskforce
you know renewable or low carbon energy
supply was that we try to avoid biofuels
generated from things like wood pellets
that the drags plant is producing
because so they're so damaging and
unsustainable we wanted to try to
exclude those so absolutely absolutely
right there There is obviously a limited
amount of waste vegetable oil going to
be available unless we all start eating
a lot of McDonald's chip products I
suppose we could do that in the
interests of the environment um but you
know these are all obviously issues that
we need to contend with we're in fairly
new territory I'll hand over to someone
else who can make more sense of the
question or anyone else like to comment
possibly just on the the renewing of the
fleet section of your question there
counselor won't always say endless azzam
when our fleet is up for renewal we will
absolutely be looking at what all of the
options are available to us and clearly
we want to move away from our diesel
fleet as quickly as possible and there
at this point in time electric is being
developed by by people like Dennis Eagle
and some other manufacturers be easy
the early days and the most of them are
just trials at the moment but absolutely
clearly that is going to if that
technology is going to improve and
become more available to us so each time
that we have vehicles that we need to
renew councillor Ward was absolutely
right 20 23 is the next year that most
of our fleet is up for renewal is
possibly unlikely I'd say that that
those the refuse vehicles are going to
be fully available by that point however
we absolutely are keeping a really close
eye on what technology is developing and
when so as soon as those opportunities
come up we can take them a number of
councils and take the opportunity to to
renew their fleet to new technologies on
a phased basis so for instance at the
moment that technology around refuse
vehicles is there is more than double
the cost of a diesel vehicle at the
moment so clearly a lot of councils
can't even afford to move over to a
fourth fleet renewal so they're taking
it piece by piece so it's quite common
to have different technologies running
on on routes within the waste service so
we will absolutely take the opportunity
to look every time our fleet is up for
renewal thanks guys thank you
Thank You Cassandra thank you right I do
want to move on quite soon we've had
quite a lot of questions but two more
then councillor McCrory from Baber has
been waiting there for quite some time
so I'll go back to him before finally
ask the hands keep changing here council
McCraw I'm trying to get my screen up
hang on
can see you you can see me that's
wonderful I think we've got a delay
again can you hear me
yes thank you my screen doesn't show
that it's just a putt couple of points
of clarification in the interim I pulled
out the joint local plan and I've
checked a couple of things because I've
taken questions on this from a resident
or two on the subject of building
regulations and and what I was able to
say around regarding building
regulations is that those are being
dealt with in a government
re-examination of the entire scope of
building regulations and much as we are
required to comply and be not
subservient but certainly in compliance
with the national planning policy
framework so would we be with building
regulations that our policies LP 23 and
LP 25 specifically deal with sustainable
construction and design for LP 23 and
energy sources storage and distribution
in LP 25 and I can see no conflict as
councillor Arthur has suggested in those
but some of this some of this stuff
let's be frank about this is not within
our gift what I think the the cabinet
are debating today is what is within our
gift what could be in the future and I
think the points been made this is a
starting point we've got a baby in the
bath water we want it to be a bigger
baby maybe we'd like it to do more but
it's doing something that we weren't
doing before and it's making steps maybe
they're baby steps and maybe the baby
could be bigger but it is the baby we've
got and and I don't think we should just
just chuck that out because we don't
like this detail or that detail I have
no objections to some of the points
being made and I do believe they can be
revisited but I have to say to a certain
extent we're given the job to a climate
change task force to report on this this
is what they've reported the people we
have to give them the responsibility to
have done that and to start rejecting or
not accepting every single part of their
conclusion seems to be a little bit
circular I don't think it's good
governance from that
interview and I can't see that this is
helping the council move forward on this
and the whole point is to move forward
the detail can be sorted later Thank You
councillor right
I have councillor Pratt and I think that
will be the last of the two I had listed
yeah thank you I did have my hand up but
I put it down after you read my name out
on your list I know that this has
already been covered but I will make I
will make my own point and ask a
question on the less on section 9.3
culture changing governance I'm a little
bit dismayed by some of the dialogue
earlier on and about you know in defense
of the fossil fuel industry it does make
it sound like the gut the Council is
slightly apologetic for fossil fuels and
my concern and my question is you know
if you continue to invest in fossil fuel
interests how do you know that they're
not going to use their money in order
for exploration extraction and the
production of fossil fuel products
rather than clean energy that we would
like to see them or personally
preferably other other companies you
know I don't and and secondly I I agree
with councilor field and council of war
boys on the fact that it doesn't need to
be fossil fuel companies there are
driving change to cleaner energy there
there are plenty of other companies in
deeds the government public money has
been used to fund big projects in the
past like railroads power stations and
communications you you name it it's it's
these big these big tickets have been
done mainly on the public public
spending in in previous times and and
then I wanted I was asked another
question regarding 2.7 and councillor
Mellon suggested that all new the old
council should build to zero carbon
standards okay we're not even then
suggesting that all new homes and all
new developments are zero carbon at this
stage we're just starting with council
homes I want to know why that's not
possible
thank you so
he said two point seven yeah two point
seven point four - sorry we don't have a
- sorry appendix G oh no you need to
look at Appendix A that's the the one
that's no paper in any case yeah my
questions still stand regarding
regarding culture change and governance
you know regarding divest by divesting
from fossil fuels how do you know that
that money will not be spent of an
extraction exploration and production of
more dirty energy and then my second
question was why can't we build all new
council hounds homes to zero carbon
standard on your first point quite
clearly the market and legislation in
countries around the world is moving to
a zero carbon basis and so those
companies are going to have to to move
with that and use their resources to
help facilitate that I see no reason why
we should rely on public financing when
they're perfectly good private companies
with the resources to be able to do this
instead
why use taxpayers money when when
there's it's perfectly available private
funding for that but in terms of your
housing moving on to all new Zero
housing casler Fleming would you like to
pick up on that one or pass onto
something else
thank you I think I probably pass on to
someone else because I think we're not
quite at the point of providing totally
zero carbon housing but it's obviously
where we want to go Jessica would you
like me to take that yes please plantman
okay so we are currently working with
consultants to develop a new design
guide and technical specification for
our affordable housing developments
this will set positive and ambitious
goals to deliver
efficient and resilient resilient
developments made to last and contribute
to our goal to be carbon neutral Thank
You Council flatten right I'll take one
more question then and that's the final
one from councillor stringer castle
stringer is is leaving the meeting right
okay we're moving on then we've now
finished the questions and I will open
this this item up now for debate from
from the the cabinet members and before
I go and ask each cabinet member in
terms if they have anything to
contribute to the debate I think we
should probably first of all pick up on
calorie burns question and to remind
everyone the question is why isn't the
cabinet showing political leadership by
taking the opportunity to convene a
citizen's assembly or similar to address
climate change across the district
engaging all residents businesses and
organizations as many other councils of
all political persuasions across the
country have done I won't go to the
council them morally I think first of
all but I will say from my point of view
I I just disagree with the initial
premise that we're not showing political
leadership I believe that by handing
over responsibility for this will be
abrogating political leadership and I
have personally very strong objections
to citizens assemblies they took for me
they're the antithesis of democracy they
tend to be stacked by activists those
that shout the loudest and the the
majority don't really get the proper
representation that wait whereas they do
through the ballot box by voting for us
so that that's my personal view on the
citizens assemblies but castlemore Lee
would you like to
say anything about this yes I think I
will thank you very much yes I I agree
we as district councillors are
democratically elected to make decisions
for our patch and as counsel Award says
if we abdicate that responsibility to an
unelected group of people however well
intentioned then there is just that it's
an abdication of responsibility
we are the democratically elected people
to go along with that now I do recognize
that sometimes we don't engage enough
with our residence and we do need to get
better at that which is why that within
our corporate outputs we already have an
item which is improved democratic
engagement with our residents and that
will be coming through it has been
delayed somewhat because of Co bead 19
and and everything else but the fact
that all of our meetings now are live
streamed everything is done in public we
are moving towards that and there will
be something coming forward towards the
end of the year Thank You councillor
Mavi see you have your hand raised the
Greek democracy used to meet in the
Agora
and we only have to look at how that
democratic country functions and
citizens assemblies like you've both
said by both chairs have said are not
elected bodies we are and therefore we
have a responsibility and being elected
we are accountable and citizens
assemblies are not accountable to anyone
by definition thank you very much thank
you there's any other member of either
the two cabinets wish to comment on this
because I think the general consensus is
that citizen
assemblies are not for us we are
democratic districts can I say something
let me guess of course yes um I think I
mean I agree I don't think we need to
set up a formal citizen assembly per se
however I do think that there is a real
place here for involving people in
shaping the climate change agenda and I
think part of the work going forward so
to speak will be in involving
communities parishes and people more in
how we do this I think all of us has
some representatives need to reach out
and actively try to get our residents to
interact with us on us on this topic I
mean I I have tried in my own wards at
parish council meetings you know talking
about climate change environment saying
please do contact me with your ideas etc
etc I have to admit I haven't heard a
lot of response so not as much as I'd
hoped
so I do I wouldn't wash this out as
something we can do better because up
because I think it probably is I think
there may be a place for having you know
some joint parish meetings to discuss
actions as they actually take shape and
affect people to get some interaction
going there so um that would be my view
on it
Thank You castle that does make sense
right okay I think we probably discussed
this issue
enough but I will now go through each
each member of the two cabinets for any
further comments that anyone wishes to
make so firstly councillor Arthi do you
have anything else you wish to
contribute to this yeah yeah just a few
things probably I think the good thing
is that most of the questions and
comments that we've heard were not
particularly negative in principle which
is good and I think that shows how hard
we worked in the group to try and
include views from across both councils
there is one little thing that's cropped
up in the questions twice I think that I
wanted to comment on I think it was
first of all brought up by John failed
and then by Daniel Pratt later on and
it's about fossil fuel companies and I
think you you said John yourself that
they're energy companies these days and
I just wanted to say something about
that because the I think you can say we
shouldn't be relying I think that was
the word that that John failed used we
shouldn't be relying on them to develop
alternatives but by the same token we
shouldn't be discounting them because
they are involved in a lot of research
into energy production not from fossil
fuels renewable energy and whether they
got their resources from developing
fossil fuels in the past or not you
can't deny that they do have
considerable resources that a lot of the
smaller startup companies don't have so
we shouldn't be discounting the
contribution that they can make to
alternatives and the last thing I was
going to say is that we're not deciding
on everything for the next 10 years
today this is not a decision today and
nothing else is going to be done for the
next 10 years and what we say today is
fixed this is going to be subject to
review as we progress so I think it's an
excellent starting point I'm sure there
will be more things that we want to do
there may be some things that we can't
do for whatever reason and and all of
this will be subject to review as we go
along so I'm I'm quite pleased with the
way that it's gone today Thank You
councillor Busby yeah just a couple of
points 12.4 the point that Andrew
stringer brought up early on which was
referring to emerging technologies I'm
not certain
I agree with him they're not emerging I
think they're now fully fledged and I
think we should be we should take that
word out or replace it with something
like key technologies or expanding
technologies it's a bit more they're a
bit further along the lines than
emerging and I think the other point
that you we need to consider for that
response about where we invest our
pension funds we're talking about what
impact we can do to make ourselves
carbon neutral that well I don't think
that'll help whatever we do with our
investments is not good to achieve what
we do okay thank you in terms of an
alternative word well we could just
replace the word emerging with
low-carbon I guess or um carbon
reduction technologies yeah
carbon reduction yeah yeah yeah let's do
that then
yes so I'm fine with either death or low
carbon well he's talking about energy
efficiency which isn't necessarily local
so carbon reduction I think carbon
reductions fine with me okay good time
to say I'm not sure about that because
LPG is lower carbon but that doesn't
mean it's a solution no do you like to
use their cars Marathi um I'm not sure
if we're talking if we're talking about
the the wording in paragraph 12 point 4
instead of emerging I think I think this
is what Dave Busby was getting at should
it be something like developing
technologies because that also picks up
on Andrew stringers point earlier on
that we shouldn't call them alternative
because some of them have been about for
centuries so should it be developing
technical
Jesus I mean I don't know really but I'm
just making the point that we shouldn't
be committing ourselves to lower carbon
but okay okay
developing castle stringers just
suggested evolving in in the chat pane
but I'm happy with developing yes sorry
too much going on my screen here
let's have to be fine yeah I'm conscious
you're looking at section four paragraph
twelve point four and discussing
possible change is the monitor officer
may wish to contradict me but but my
view would be the report is the report
yeah you of course can make changes to
an amend the recommendations but the
wording and the report is as you have
received it you've given commentary and
you are currently collectively
discussing what you think that should or
shouldn't look like I think that's fine
and the minutes would record that I
don't think you need to come up with a
an alternative form of words for the
report that's already been published and
took place but we fair enough thank you
Cutler Davis
do you have anything you wish to
contribute at this stage Ella Davis I'll
come back castle Amalfi see anything
else you wish to say at this point no
councillor Osborn yeah Thank You mr.
chairman just two actually just to agree
with councillor Arthi this is not in
stone this is an evolving action plan
and will change as we move forward you
know especially I'm just thinking
specifically with housing you know
there'll be new technology new
construction methods coming forward and
those things those changes will be
picked up on and the plan the action
plan will be changed accordingly so I
think as it stands it's it's it's an
excellent plan and as I said previously
my introduction you know I think it's
brilliant it's a really big step forward
and I look forward to this being
delivered in the future Thank You mr.
Jim thank you Kesler Parker no chair
nope no other points to raise I was
going to make a point but Arthur said
exactly as I'd like my thoughts already
were that we didn't need to get stuck on
particular wordings but no no the
comments of the stage chair thanks okay
thank you and and all I'd like to say at
this stage is to reiterate what's been
said by karthika Osborn it is an
excellent plan the cross-party working
group has certainly done an excellent
job and come up with something which is
entirely deliverable as a starter it
will evolve as our aspiration has
changed and as our ability to do things
and not not least to finance things
changes but at this point I think this
is it's realistic and and a very good
example of what we can do collectively
moving on to the midst of members now
councillor Brewster do you have anything
you wish to contribute no I don't really
mr. chairman I just feel that you know
to get on with this and progress it will
be excellent
okay Thank You castle burn Thank You
chair in the previous administration
I was the environment portfolio holder
and I I knew this was likely to be one
of the key issues of the next
administration and I was wondering at
that time you know quite how if if I
carried on with that job I would have
ever would have approached it and to me
it was a pretty daunting prospect um
fortunately should I say fortunately I'm
not sure it wasn't it wasn't my job
after all
I was I was moved into a different
portfolio and I have to say that I think
that my successor here and the team
behind her and Liz on the bay beside
have done a superb job of setting this
out and giving us an amazing foundation
on which to on which to start to build
know and deliver what we what we know we
can deliver so um I'm just looking
forward to seeing it seeing it develop
seeing open up seeing it start to
deliver its promises as I'm sure it will
so I don't have anything to add to a
debate that's likely to change that view
Thank You castle on Castle Flatman
really to reiterate what counts and a
burn has just said and others gone
before um let's just get on with it
yep Thank You castle Fleming do you have
anything more you wish to contribute
I'll just just have a quick word I just
um I think Andrew stringer has made a
point in the chat that probably the word
we needed in 12.4 is evolving and I
think you know let's take that on board
in
thinking we can't change the report but
thank you Andrew for that and you know
this is all dynamic I think we're used
to things being set in stone and being
sort of written in concrete and they
aren't where we're dealing with a
dynamic plan and our local plan believe
it or not is dynamic as well as soon as
it's approved we'll be working on the
next iteration so you know changes is
what life is about these days and we've
got to be to get used to dealing with
uncertainty and being comfortable with
it and you know with that in mind you
know I just like to thank everyone who
worked on the task force
I hope the task force can carry on the
work and do you know do things at a
different level once once we've got this
going thank you
Thank You castle flaming castle gold
thank you Thank You chair start by
saying I don't say entirely disagree
with your observations about citizens
assemblies I think it is a matter for
local authorities to take the lead in
these matters and I think the approach
that has been taken which is there to
constitute the task force across parties
across the councils is absolutely the
right way again and I think it often in
these discussions what happens is that
we end up spending our time talking
about points of difference maybe worth
where we don't see things entirely the
same way the trouble with that is that
we lose sight of the fast majority of
issues and proposals on which there is
such wide wide agreement the acid test
now is about is about delivery because
having the ideas and proposals is one
thing delivering them is another I'm
delighted that from the mid Suffolk end
that we've been able to make that
provision subject to all of the
requirements
so bad business cases being prepared and
we know don't we that half a million
though is far from insignificant will
won't ultimately be enough to do all
that we you need to do but I would like
to applaud and commend all of those that
have been involved in the task force at
work and the action plan that is
resulted which i think is excellent
thank you very much Thank You councillor
Morley Thank You chair I would I'm
really excited about this the task
force's worked incredibly hard and it's
always really difficult to to coalesce
so many different views into into one
strategic document and I think the task
force and our officers I have done a
fantastic job on this I'm really looking
forward and I'm really excited about
delivering the items that fall within my
portfolio I'm really looking forward to
working with my officers on this to be
honest I think they've already started
because we have no intention of waiting
so things are already under way and I'm
really excited about the papers that are
going to be coming before us in the
not-too-distant future thank you thank
you
Thank You chair and I similarly also
welcome what I think is a significant
undertaking by both councils I think
it's very clear through the report and
the range of recommendations that we've
been asked to consider independence
after an enormous amount of work has
gone into this and so I think we should
in the first instance thank the climate
change task force and kastenov our team
as well for their contributions in
producing this report in my view these
proposals represent an enormous step
change in the way that we work I don't
believe we should understate the
challenges that we will face
implementing this but I do believe that
what these measures will be immensely
important to the environment and are
also as Casto Gould alluded to they are
I think robust well thought through and
hopefully will ultimately be deliverable
and I personally just I know this is
obviously the the beginning of a very
long process but I believe this report
will make a real difference in reducing
our carbon emissions of both districts
and I am actually especially proud of
the fact that we will be aiming to
achieve Net Zero 20 years ahead of the
UK government itself and so for those
reasons I will be supporting the
recommendations in this report and hope
that both cabinet's will endorse it as
well thank you very much
finally Council Whitehead thank you I
think this exciting times ahead I think
there's a lot of emerging technology
that is still to emerge whilst I listen
to the debate I was also googling and
Founder an investment company it says
our purpose is to reimagining energy for
people in our planet we want to help the
world to reach Net Zero and improve
people's lives
I mean whilst as companies like that out
there this was called beyond petroleum
or BP I think there's a you know that
the future is bright
yeah thank you very much right well I
think we're coming to the end before we
move to the vote just want counselor Mel
VC you and I proposed and seconded
this but I would like to ask you if you
prepare to accept an amendment to 3.3
[Music]
and or HRA at the end of the paragraph
so do we agree funding from the general
fund and or HRA yep okay yes sorry and
that that that's the amended
recommendation for for babe so now can
we move to the vote please Claire would
you like to conduct that for us please
you checked so when I call your name if
you could answer for against our name
counselor our fee for counsel oppose be
a big fool counselor Davis
that's the Davises had to leave the
meeting he's had another engagement okay
counselor Mel vz4 cancel Osborne for
that's my Parker for counsel award or
Thank You chair that's unanimous
thank you cute thank you and for mid
Suffolk councillor Brewster for
councillor ban Oh counselor flattened
for councillor Fleming for Council of
gold for councillor Morni for councillor
Richardson for and councillor Whitehead
for Thank You chair again that is
unanimous great Thank You Claire well
that brings this meeting to a close
thank you everyone the agenda does say
that the next meeting is in August but
the likelihood is that the August
meeting certainly fit for Weber is going
to be postponed or canceled rather and
the agenda items picked up in September
I believe Castle Morrie that'll be the
same for mid Suffolk yes I believe so
yeah well thank you very much everyone
and can we terminate the live feed now
please thank you
you
you